how do you manage business and family
I'm gonna answer that question in
today's episode of luncheon urn so
recently got asked the question for one
of my Twitter followers love you guys
Imran who wrote in to say hi Evan is
there a family cost of being a
successful entrepreneur this is a
fantastic question and I think one that
every entrepreneur struggles with how
much time do I spend in my business how
much time I spend in my family and today
I'm gonna share three ways that I manage
my business and my family and hopefully
you can learn from it as well so number
one is step boundaries one of the most
important things I think that you can do
is figure out when you are going to work
and when you are gonna be with your
family and I think too many
entrepreneurs let that lead too much
there's no clear definition as to when
family time starts and when work time
starts one of the things that can
definitely help is start working when
your spouse starts working I find that
prior I used to wake up a little bit
later than my wife and I would start
working later than she would and I find
it it's easier to wake up at the same
time and while she's working I'm working
and then when she gets home I'm not
working anymore and having that clear
definition I think really helps recently
I've taken over a new business and I've
I've tried to juggle my time and had to
figure out okay now I've got a service
possibilities where can I make that fit
in my schedule and Nina was awesome and
suggested hey why don't we take some
time on Monday night and you can work on
this and I'll do some other stuff and
and I said no because I want to make
sure that the time that we're spending
together is together and not letting the
work bleed too much into our lives and
there's gonna be some days where you
have this emergencies where you can't
help it where something comes up when
you have to deal with it and hopefully
work on minimizing those emergencies I
like running a low emergency business
and no crisis business as much as
possible but basically planning around
this for that when you are working
you're working those are your work hours
you have a set schedule and when you
have your family time that's your family
time number two is involve them and this
is something that I grossly
underestimate the importance of earlier
in
my career I used to think that you know
running the business was my problem my
challenge and I didn't want that to
bleed into my personal life and not have
to make you know my my spouse and my
child worried about what I was doing but
the more that I've understood them the
more at least in my case I've realized
that they like to be involved they like
to know what's happened they like to be
at least understanding what's going on
in my business because it gives them
better contacts and so sometimes it can
help
so Nina's in a bunch of my videos
Hayden's in a bunch of my videos Nina
now helps comments respond to the
comments on the channel and that's all
fantastic and she gets an understanding
of why I'm doing this why it's so
important but even me just explaining
what's going on and not in the
frustrating way but talking about what's
happening in my day and why it's
important what I'm worried about that
makes it feel like we're on the same
team it makes it feel like SH in there
stands me more and it's not something
that I ever really needed so much I feel
personally just as a piece of
self-awareness that I don't really need
that validation where other people I
don't need other people to understand me
or comfort me for the most part but for
her it's important that she feels
connected to me in what I'm doing and so
I think if you can find ways to involve
your partner your family if it's just
them understanding what you're doing or
if there's a way that they can help in
some way that makes them feel a little
closer a little more connected to you I
feel like it really helps and my last
bit of advice is spend quality time
together I think you can definitely
increase the amount of time you spend
together but you want to make sure that
the time that you do spend together is
quality time I think too many people
might be with their significant other
but they're spending the time on their
phones and they're just watching a TV
show and they're not actually spending
quality time I'd much rather have an
hour of quality time with my wife where
we're talking or having dinner together
or dancing together and we feel some
kind of close connection then two hours
of just sitting watching a show or being
on opposite sides of a room checking our
phones I feel like that's not a real
connection so you want to make sure that
the limited amount of time that you have
in general right our time is limited and
everything that we do for your business
for your family for your hobbies for
your frame
your time is limited and you want to
make sure that every minute that you're
using counts for something and it's
helping you form a meaningful connection
and that is that's minutes that you'll
never get back and so make sure that the
time you're spending with your family is
quality time so those are my three
suggestions I'd love to know how you
balance your family and your business
leave a comment below maybe I could
learn something as well thank you so
much for watching you need to believe
and I'll see you soon